[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heutige fast
traditionell palästinensische sauber wir
machen heute muss ein röllchen muss
sachen ist eigentlich eine
palästinensische bzw jordanische
spezialität da macht man das brot
schichtet man mit hähnchen mit leckeren
gewürzen und zwiebeln
ich habe heute röhrchen daraus bin ich
irgendwann packte schauen das sieht auch
cool aus und bekam darauf dass war vom
paar wochen als wir nämlich die damals
drei geplant haben und dann haben sie in
der küche schauen und sagen wir mal auch
dazu gange war
und ich weiß ganz genau kann sagte wenn
sie mal mama wie hieß noch einmal die so
reich wirst du geredet und dann halt ist
jedoch bekomme solche sachen
und dann habe ich es total gut empfunden
und dass man probieren dachtet
bordmechaniker muss ich unbedingt zeigen
und jetzt machen wir das einfach sagt
also für die füllung benötigen wir
zuallererst hähnchenbrust hier habe ich
zwei ganze ich sage euch aber die gramm
zahl auf jeden fall noch mal schreibe
ich euch eine infobox
außerdem an gewürzen und das ist die
unterste gewürz das ist ganz bitter
ebenfalls ist das zu marquez ich bin
gewiss dazu sage ich euch gleich noch
was
außerdem salz und pfeffer etwas zimt und
safran falls jetzt ein bisschen
abgeschreckt sagt safran wo bekomme ich
das her also ich hab jetzt aus dem
orientalischen supermarkt falls ihr das
nicht her bekommt lass es einfach weg
ist gar kein problem
das gleiche gilt jetzt auch für zehn
falls ist unter euch welche gibt die
absolut kein zimt mögen dann macht es
einfach nicht rein aber man schmeckt s
nicht ganz so auf das schmeckt trotzdem
sehr sehr lecker
desweiteren benötigen wir olivenöl und
pinienkerne die rüsten wir später noch
an
außerdem zwiebeln die habe ich hier
schon in so feine streifen geschnitten
und nochmal unser zu marx und
desweiteren nochmals salz ist ratlos
warum
[Applaus]
warum das ist alles an einem tag
geschafft
wenn die zubereitung für die füllung
müssen wir jetzt unsere hähnchenbrust
gar kochen einfach in einem großen topf
das wasser aufkochen und dann rein geben
das dauert jetzt ne weile und in der
zwischenzeit gehe ich hier über für
anderen herdplatte und rüste da in der
fettfreien beschichteten pfanne die
pinienkerne an
wir haben uns gerade gegenüber dich
beigebracht was pinienkernen auf unserem
sprachen heißt zum beispiel heißt das
arabische snowboard noch türkisch und
die sind jetzt schon an gerüstet und
jetzt gebe ich dir mal hier rein
so schreibt mir doch mal was
pinienkernen auf eurer sprache heißt das
wird nicht passieren schreibt sinn meine
kommentare auf russisch heißt es
bestimmt pinienkerne noch ski oder oder
polnisch oder so schreibt es mal
rechtzeitig sehr interessieren so und
wir warten jetzt noch auf die
hähnchenbrust ist es einmal durch gab
nach ca 30 minuten sind die
hähnchenbrustfilets gar und jetzt will
ich sie einfach raus und den hühner sot
den dürft ihr auf keinen fall
wegschütten damit könnt ihr richtig
lecker resort oder reis kochen
so und jetzt lasse ich das aber kurz
ausdampfen damit ich mir gleich nicht
die finger verbrennen und dann machen
wir weiter als nächstes rufen wir die
hähnchenbrust filets mit den händen
auseinander so dass wir richtig kleine
stücke haben
[Musik]
so das salz ist schon drin und jetzt
gebe ich auch noch zimt und safran rein
und safran nehme ich immer gern auch
zwischen die hände um noch so ein
bisschen kleiner zu machen so quasi und
jetzt kommt das mag mit hinzu das ist
die wichtigste zutat in diesem rezept
das ist unser essig baum gehört das
findet in jedem türkischen oder
arabischen supermarkt
[Musik]
das besondere an zu marx ist dass es
reich an antioxidantien ist das heißt es
neutralisiert die freien radikale
und es ist sogar entzündungshemmend also
ich versuche so mag immer wieder zu
integrieren sei es im salat oder in
herzhaften speisen
das mädchen habe ich jetzt kurz an die
seite gegeben denn wir machen nichts
weiter mit unseren zwiebeln und dafür
gebe ich ihnen allen tiefen topf etwas
öl so und dann mit zwiebeln rein
es mag zwar ein bisschen viel öl
vorkommen aber das muss so sein also
nimmt auf jeden fall die menge öl und
jetzt gebe ich noch salz pfeffer und
nochmals so mack in die masse würde das
noch mal gut um und dann geht es weiter
natürlich hätte man pfeffer auch in die
hähnchenmast mit rein nehmen können aber
das macht nichts denn am ende wird das
sowieso alles eine masse
[Musik]
nach circa eineinhalb minuten sind die
zwiebeln angebraten und jetzt geben wir
die härchen was mit da zum braten das um
so zwei drei minuten an
[Musik]
zudem habe ich jetzt ausgeschaltet und
zu guter letzt kommt zieht ihn intern
betreiben werden gut unter gehoben und
dann geht es weiter dann werden die
röschen befüllt
[Musik]
zum einen rollen brauchen wir jetzt noch
lava sport das habe ich jetzt vom türken
ansonsten falls ihr das nicht findet
dann könnt ihr auch gerne annehmen wobei
ich muss sagen also was schmeckt schon
ein bisschen besser
oder wenn es gar nicht anders geht dann
in die luft es schmeckt auch total
lecker aber mit lounge ist es einfach
traditionellen original das macht gerade
die packung auf und dann zeige ich euch
nicht das ganze einrollen
dieses lager sport ist schon so
rechteckig deshalb nehme ich mir das
jetzt so längst und gibt da jetzt die
füllung drauf
sobald die füllung jetzt schön verteilt
habt habt ihr das einmal ungewollt das
ganze schön eng ein so an der stelle
schneide ich das allerdings ab weil mir
das sonst zu viel brot wird
[Musik]
und jetzt schneidet ihr euch beliebig
lange stücke heraus
[Musik]
die restliche menge der haben sie
nämlich gerade leinwand hier eingeworfen
mache ich jetzt mit mehr brot er mag es
mit mehr brot ich mag das mit weniger
entscheidet das einfach selber also wenn
ihr mehr brot mögt dann rollt ist
einfach zwei oder drei mal mehr ein
kiki die röhrchen kommen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
und unterhitze bis sie richtig schön
goldbraun sind und so sehen die muss
sachen röllchen nach dem backen aus zehn
minuten hat so hat das ganze gedauert
und richtig schön goldbraun jetzt müssen
wir sie noch mit öl bestreichen entweder
nimmt die olivenöl oder falls sie den
intensiven geschmack auf den röhrchen
nicht so mag dann möglich max dann nimmt
gerne etwas geschmolzene butter
für die garnierung gebe ich jetzt noch
etwas zu marc drauf und bei diesem
rezept ihr habt es wahrscheinlich schon
gemerkt ist total wichtig ich kann es
euch verzeihen wenn ihr sagt in der
familie markt die man keine zwiebeln
dann kommt dann lass die weg aber so mag
leute zu marc muster rein unbedingt das
hat so einen säuerlichen geschmack und
so ein bisschen herb also bis unbedingt
aus bis zu mach ich bin so gespannt auf
euer feedback selbst gebe ich da noch
ein bisschen was drauf für die deko
[Musik]
also demos sachen wolf sind jetzt fertig
sie werden traditionell mit joghurt
verspeist allerdings mit warmen joghurt
ich bin ehrlich es ist nicht so meins
ist nämlich bei den ganz normalen
naturjoghurt ihr könnt ja gern noch ein
bisschen knoblauch reintun salz und
pfeffer wenn ihr möchtet aber erst da
schon die gewürze alle mit drin
falls ihr jetzt fragt soll ich dazu noch
was servieren was meinst du also für
mich persönlich erreicht das weil wir
haben ja vorher noch die suppe das könnt
ihr gerne mit einem salat servieren
würde das ziemlich vorkommen reichen
falls ja muss noch eine beilage her dann
verlinke ich euch in die info box mine
reis und meine kartoffelchips von denen
ich denke dass die gute zu passen so ich
freue mich jetzt wenn ihr die muss
sachen holz nach macht und mir fotos mit
dem hashtag iges kitchen auf instagram
zukommen lässt darüber freue ich mich
immer sehr gucken auch mal jedes
einzelne an ich verlinke euch die
genauen mengenangaben wie immer unten in
der infobox und ansonsten sage ich bis
zum nächsten mal auf die die skizzen
[Musik]
also wir machen gerade muss sachen
röhrchen dass jemand von euch sehr
interessieren hier im ständigen angriffe
einstelle
nein aber ich musste sagen doch fehler
gemacht so oft rezept ist für 250
pinienkerne ausgelegt es klappt nicht
mehr
[Musik]